it's an act of love because they're
Democrats and it's not just we played it
the other day who was it Claire
mccaskill former Senator Claire
mccaskill she said it was the ultimate
Act of love Joe Biden defending his son
stocky it's an act of love and
unfortunately we do have to show you a
clip of one of the ladies on The View
and it's an active well it's not an act
of love coming from me but it's an act
of love from well you got it Go the
hunter Biden story
the Scandal the this that it's also the
story of a Father's Love and Joe Biden
has never and will never give up on his
son son Hunter and will never treat him
lesser than and so he is a father first
take it or leave he's a father first
he's a father first this is the same
father who told us repeatedly that he's
never discussed business dealings with
his son what a great dad he's got a son
the son's got some problems obviously
crack addict whatever son's working at a
Ukrainian Energy company his dad is vice
president was pressuring to get a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired like there's
a whole bunch of stuff there they never
talked about it he's such a great father
and he loves his son so much he never
said a son what do you do for a living
by the way are you are you working for
uh
never did that never did that
the point of today's show guys is to
show you that everything they do is
designed to make regular sane people
think that they're crazy that is what
they are doing to us they are trying to
Gaslight us all into thinking that
they're right about everything and we're
wrong about everything and we can only
question things when they want us to
question them and if we Dare Challenge
The Narrative we're going to be labeled
what they used to do to Trump what
they're now doing to RFK Jr what they do
all the reasons why you and your own
personal life probably don't say all the
things that you think you should say or
that you believe because that they keep
everyone in this non-stop state of fear
[Music]
thank you